part three
of if you get pregnant it is your own
damn fault okay
women are acting like these men want
a bunch of children running around okay
number one there are knit cannons okay
nick cannons exist but he is an
exception to the rule
do you think
that drake
drake wanted to have a kid with an adult
film star no
no do you think the adult film star
wanted his kid yes
yes
this man's putting hot sauce
in its condoms so that doesn't happen
again most men aren't gonna think of
that
these these girls be turkey-bastering
children
and guys all we have to do all we gotta
do okay
birth control
abstinence okay
track your cycle wear a condom
if you did one of the four you would
probably be fine
probably
and then every girl will come up and say
well i know someone this is the
exception to the rule guys we're not
talking about the exception to the rule
and no
pull out is not a good form of birth
control
okay
um anyways i'm done
i'm done that's it
sorry that's the end of my rant today
please subscribe i'm getting real poor
you know what i mean please
bye